>> YEAH, YOU ALREADY KNOW.
♪ TURN IT UP
TURN IT UP
YEAH ♪
♪ WE IN THE CLUB
AND WE TURN IT UP
PINKIE WORTH TWO FIFTY THOU
WOW ♪
♪ DOUBLE THAT UP
IN MY MOUTH ♪
SHOW THAT SHE BAD
LIKING MY SWAG ♪
♪ PLUS SHE GOT ALL OF
THAT ASS BOOTY
GETTING THAT CASH
HATERS BE MAD ♪
♪ FRIENDOS WE STAY
ON THAT BAG COOKING ♪
♪ WAKE UP IN THE MORNING WITH
SOME BITCHES
AND I'M SMILING ♪
♪ BUT WE GOT TO
PUT IN WORK
IF WE WANT TO STAY
SHINING ♪
♪ WE GO TO THERAPY
THERAPY THERAPY
THERAPY ♪
♪ WE SPENT A MILLION
ON THERAPY
ANGELA ANGELA
ANGELA ANGELA ♪
♪ TWICE A WEEK WE GO TO ANGELA ♪
HEY!
>> GO ON.
>> YEAH.
IT'S JUST LIKE, EVERY TIME I
BRING UP EMOTIONAL CONFLICT, HE
ALWAYS WANT TO --
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, LET'S USE, I
FEEL STATEMENTS.
>> OH, MY BAD.
I FEEL LIKE EVERY TIME I BRING
UP EMOTIONAL CONFLICT, HE WANTS
TO TALK ABOUT THE LAMBO.
>> LAMBO.
>> BUT IT'S GOT THE SUICIDE
DOORS THOUGH.
>> ENOUGH WITH THE LAMBO, MAN!
>> LAMBO.
>> JUST TALK TO ME DOG.
♪ SHE WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
OUR MAMAS MAMAS
ALL OF OUR FEARS AND OUR
TRAUMAS BAD ♪
♪ HOMIES BE ASKING
ME STUFF BUT
I DON'T BE OPENING UP
I'M FINE ♪
♪ SOMETIMES I CRY
I DON'T KNOW WHY
I JUST BE WANTING TO
FIGHT AGGRESSION ♪
♪ LAMBO ON DUBS
DOORS GOING UP
YOU KNOW I DON'T
GIVE A ♪
>> SEE, YOU'RE DEFLECTING.
DO YOU SEE THAT?
I THINK YOU DO CARE.
>> NO.
>> DOG, WHOSE IDEA WAS IT TO BUY
THE LAMBO IN THE FIRST PLACE?
>> LAMBO!
>> MINE.
>> NO, NO, I SHOWED YOU TWO
MONTHS AGO ON INSTAGRAM.
I SAID, I WANT THE ICE
CREAM-COLORED LAMBO WITH THE
SUICIDE DOORS.
GUESS WHO PULLED UP TO THE STRIP
CLUB THE VERY NEXT WEEK LOOKING
LIKE A DESERT ON WHEELS.
>> PULL UP.
>> SOUNDS LIKE THAT ICE CREAM
LAMBO WAS IMPORTANT TO YOU, AND
WHEN HE BOUGHT IT FIRST, YOU
FELT --
>> INVISIBLE!
>> VISIBLE.
>> YOU NEEDED HIM TO HEAR YOU,
BUT INSTEAD OF BEING PRESENT, HE
WAS GONE.
>> SKRT SKRT.
>> LOOK, I SEE THAT I HURT YOU.
I'M SORRY, DOG.
I THINK I WAS ACTING UP BECAUSE
I JUST MISSED OUR FRIENDSHIP.
YOU KNOW, BEFORE THE MONEY,
BEFORE THE LAMBO.
>> LAMBO.
>> HEY MAN.
I MISS THAT TOO.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
YOU THINK WE CAN WORK ON THAT?
>> WE SURE CAN.
>> WOW, DO YOU SEE WHAT THAT
WAS?
>> HEY.
♪ EY EY EYE Y
EY BREAKTHROUGH
BREAKTHROUGH BREAKTHROUGH
BREAKTHROUGH ♪
♪ STUNT ON THESE
HOES WITH MY BREAKTHROUGH
STUNT ON THEM ♪
♪ WE GOT SOME ISSUES
HAND ME SOME TISSUES ♪
>> WE HAVEN'T HEARD MUCH FROM
YOU TODAY.
>> HUH?
>> YOU HAVEN'T SPOKEN UP AT ALL.
>> YEAH, I HAVE.
I'VE BEEN REPEATING --
>> REPEATING WHAT THESE TWO SAY,
I KNOW, BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
NOBODY CARES WHAT I THINK.
I JUST DO THE AD LIB.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE, MAN.
COME ON MAN.
>> LET'S LET HIM SPEAK.
>> FIRST OF ALL, DON'T INTERRUPT
ME BITCH.
I'M TALKING TO MY BROTHER.
>> YEAH, WELL INSTEAD OF TALKING
BITCH, HOW ABOUT YOU LISTEN?
>> OH, DAMN.
>> I GUESS I JUST ASSUME THAT
YOU GUYS LIKE PITY ME.
LIKE, Y'ALL DON'T REALLY WANT ME
AROUND.
>> NO, MAN.
YOU FUNNY.
>> YEAH.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH, MAN.
>> THANK YOU, BECAUSE YOU KNOW I
ACTUALLY BE THINKING ABOUT MY
JOKES, AND STUFF.
>> MAN, DON'T START CRYING, MAN.
YOU START CRYING, AND I'LL START
CRYING.
>> WHY DON'T YOU LET IT OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
WHOO.
WHOO, WHOO, WHOO, WHOO!
♪ GROUP HUG
GROUP HUG
GROUP HUG ♪
♪ ME AND MY HOMIES DO
GROUP HUGS GROWTH
IN THERAPY THERAPY
THERAPY THERAPY ♪
♪ WE MAKE IT RAIN ON
OUR THERAPIST
DAMN ANGELA SEXY ♪
>> WELL, THAT'S ALL THE TIME WE
HAVE.
>> ALL RIGHT, WELL.
>> I GUESS YOU CAN --
[ TALKING OVER EACH OTHER ]
>> HEY.
>> HEY, HEY, WHAT'S UP ASAP?
>> FRIENDOS!
>> YO, WHAT'S HAPPENING, BRO.
YO I PEEPED THE ICE CREAM LAMBO
PARKED OUT FRONT.
IT'S HOT.
>> THANKS.
THAT WAS HIS IDEA.
>> DAMN.
♪♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]